so senator Sanders you're gonna run for
president I am going to run for
president that's correct
what's gonna be different this time
we're gonna win
we are gonna also launch what I think is
unprecedented in modern American history
and that is a grassroots movement John
which will have at least 1 million
people from every state in this country
coming together to not only defeat
Donald Trump not only to win the
Democratic nomination but also to lay
the groundwork for transforming the
economic and political life of this
country that's what's different and
that's your theory which is that without
the without the groundswell without the
grassroots you can't change the apology
that's exactly right
look John we are the only major country
on Earth not to guarantee healthcare to
all and the reason for that is the power
of the insurance companies we pay by far
the highest prices in the world for
prescription drugs that's the pot power
of the pharmaceutical industry we have a
corrupt political system in which
billionaires can't contribute unlimited
sums of money that's the power of the
top one percent in the billionaire class
and on and on it goes so somebody can
come before you and say look I want to
do a and I want to do B and that's fine
but at the end of the day the only way
that real change takes place is when
millions of people stand up fight back
and say enough is enough we're gonna
have a government that works for all of
us not just a few this time you're
running in a field with a lot more
Democrats how has the field changed
since the last time you well obviously
it's a different campaign last time was
just Secretary Clinton and now we'll
have who knows 10 15 20 candidates
doesn't it make it harder in some ways
it does in some ways that makes it easy
when you're running against one person
you know you got to have 51% of the
votes now who knows what you need 30 35
% but bottom line for me is I think it
is absolutely imperative that Donald
Trump be defeated because I think it is
unacceptable and unamerican to be frank
with you that we have a president who is
a pathological liar and it gives me no
pleasure to say that
but it's true we have a president who is
a racist who is a sexist who is a
xenophobe who was doing what no
president in our lifetimes has come
close to doing and that is trying to
divide us up what presidents even
conservative presence liberal presidents
they understand their function is to
bring our people together this guy is
trying to divide us up that has got to
end
but all of your opponents will say we've
gotta get Donald Trump out of the White
House that's not your distinguishing
characteristic so that is not my
distinguishing characteristic I think
what I am very proud of in and since
this campaign John is a continuation of
what we did in 2016 you will recall you
may recall that in 2016
many of the ideas that I talked about
Medicare for all raising the minimum
wage to $15 an hour making public
colleges and universities tuition-free
spending at least the trillion dollars
and rebuilding our crumbling
infrastructure criminal justice reform
all of those ideas people was all Bernie
they're so radical they are extremely
American people just won't accept those
ideas well you know what's happened that
over three years all of those ideas and
many more are now part of the political
mainstream and a majority the American
people now support them so what this
campaign is about is understanding that
three years ago we began the political
revolution now it's time to complete
that revolution and to take those that
vision and implement it into reality so
you're saying the party came your way
well I don't want to say that I think
most people would say that is that your
argument then against your competitors
which is I was Medicare for all before
Medicare for always cool I guess that's
one way of looking at but it's no I know
many of the people certainly the
senators who are running and without
exception I am fond of them there are
some cases my friends I think maybe the
this what distinguishes this campaign
from the others it's not only that these
are issues that in fact we did raise and
and had to take on enormous opposition
as we did but also that what I
understand from the bottom of my heart
that real change in this country will
never come about unless there is
struggle unless millions of people stand
up and fight for that change we have
three people in America today own more
wealth than the bottom half of the
American Society we are the only major
country on earth not to guarantee health
care to all we pay the highest prices
for prescription drugs we have a
dysfunctional child care system we have
a president who doesn't even acknowledge
the reality of climate change let alone
take on the fossil fuel industry real
change Don is not gonna come when
somebody gets to the White House and say
oh gee members of Congress I think you
should you know take on the hundreds of
millions of dollars spent by the
pharmaceutical company do the right
thing that's not how it's gonna happen
it happens when people stand up and
fight back that's the way that real
change has always happened in this
country you used to talk about a
revolution that's what you're talking
about here that's right in other words
once again it's not gonna happen inside
the beltway the only way that Congress
and the White House is gonna move is
when millions of people really do stand
up and say enough is enough we want a
government not just rhetoric this is
reality a government that works for all
of us not just wealthy campaign
contributors did you used to say you
this is dangerous you're voting me to
myself all right what did I say
we told Bob Schieffer you said I think
it's fair to say that I'm perhaps the
most progressive member of the United
States Senate that's the last time you
ran is that still true yeah I think so
let's talk about one of those let me ask
you this is the size of the or is the
revolutionary nature of each individual
policy prescription you make whether
it's on climate change or healthcare is
the size and boldness of it
a signal of how serious you are because
some of your competitors will be saying
well let's have Medicare for all but
let's not do as much as Bernie Sanders
once does that mean they're not as
serious I don't want it look these are
my friends these are good and serious
people so I'm not here to criticize
my opponents and I hope that the
campaign that will take place within the
Democratic a primary possible process
will be won on issues and not personal
attacks I think all that I'm saying here
is that what I understand from the
bottom of my heart is that a time went
for example the drug companies make
billions and billions of dollars in
profits that they themselves will spend
hundreds of millions of dollars to
prevent a medicare-for-all you gotta
take them on so does through many
members of Congress say we're at a lower
drug prices almost everybody recognizes
that but you cannot make those changes
unless there is a movement of people who
make the Congress and the President and
offer they cannot refuse here's why I
asked there is a debate in the
Democratic Party which you know so well
about whether your proposals are just
too big for the system of government as
it exists right now they're just too
large you talk about a revolution but
other candidates are saying we need a
more yes increase the number of people
who are covered by health care yes it's
a right but we can't go all the way to
what Bernie Sanders is John we are
sitting here in Burlington Vermont my
hometown get on you get in your car go
50 miles north and you'll be in Quebec
Canada now somehow or another in Canada
for a number of decades they have
provided quality care to all people
without out-of-pocket expenses you go in
for cancer therapy you don't take out
your wallet and they do it for about 50
percent per capita of the cost that we
spend now if our friends in Canada can
do it if our friends in the UK can do it
in a different way if our friends in
Scandinavia can provide quality health
care to all of their people as a right
for far less cost than we spend you tell
me why we can't do it now I will tell
you the answer so I'm not gonna give you
the opportunity I'm gonna give you an
answer and that is it is not a health
care issue it is a political issue it's
an economic issue it's the power of the
insurance companies and the drug
companies and I'm prepared to take them
on let me ask you a policy question in a
political question about Medicare for
all when you go to Canada still
two-thirds of the people who have the
health care in Canada have some form of
private help with that insurance your
medicare-for-all plan as i understand it
has no private element to it well if you
want you know in Canada and what I want
is to cover all of the basic health care
needs
if people want cosmetic surgery finding
and go to a private insurance the other
thing that we do which has not been
talked about enough is I'm a strong
defender of Medicare as it currently
exists but Medicare today does not cover
dental care it does not cover eyeglasses
as its not cover hearing aids and that
is something that many seniors are
concerned about our legislation will
provide that coverage well but let me
ask you on your Medicare for all you
have talked about the fact that polls
show seventy percent are in favor of
Medicare for all but that number drops
to thirty seven if somebody hears
private insurance is going to go away
which is what your which is what your
plan offers so I guess my question is
you're offering something that the
polling shows people can get very spook
very quickly no well but that's because
we're going to be taking on the
insurance companies and the drug
companies we're going to spend a whole
lot of money distorting what we believe
in for example they're gonna say people
you're gonna lose your current health
insurance and employment yeah but you're
gonna have the same exact doctor you're
gonna have more freedom of choice on our
proposal than you have under the current
proposals so there's a lot of
misinformation that's going around on
the Scituate the bottom line is the
average middle-class family will save
money will spend less money on health
care will have more choice and have
broader coverage than it's currently the
case so the other big the other
challenge to your to your health care
plan will be cost people you can explain
it to them but they're people will say
my goodness there's no way this is
everybody's gonna get covered and there
are the estimates that come out or do
you want to help us explain the truth we
spend twice as much per capita on health
care as the Canadians all right and the
reason is we waste an enormous amount of
money in administration and an
incredibly dysfunctional and complicated
system our proposal will cost the
American people less than the current
dysfunctional system there are some
estimates by the way but over the next
ten years the current system if not
could run up to 50 trillion dollars now
here's where the dishonesty comes in
all right people say Bernie Sanders
wants to raise your taxes what they
forget to tell you is that Bernie
Sanders is gonna do away with all of
your private health private health
insurance premiums you're a family of
four John the average family now is
paying twenty eight thousand dollars a
year for health insurance that's gonna
end no more out-of-pocket expenses no
more
deductibles the cost of prescription
drugs is going to go down we expand the
kinds of coverage available for senior
citizens it's a good deal but that
transition which is essentially
transitioning from private premiums you
pay now into some federal system just
that alone is a massive transformation
of the of the federal system which just
that part of it is I mean all that crazy
currently we have Medicare right now for
the elderly guess what Medicare is
probably the most popular health
insurance program in America we have
Medicaid that's a pretty popular program
we have the bitter and Veterans
Administration which if you talk to
veterans is a pretty popular programs we
already spending a whole lot of money on
public health programs so all we are
doing is taking a popular program that
most seniors are very proud of Medicare
and we're expanding it over a four-year
period to all of our people what happens
to the 180 million people in the private
insurance market they will continue to
be able to go to the doctors they want
the hospitals they want the color of
their insurance card will change and
they will no longer be private it'll be
a public system it'll be medica right so
I mean you're adding 180 million people
to Medicare so that'll take it a little
doing look back in 1965 I think Medicare
was establish and everybody said oh my
god it's impossible this is communism
this is taking away everybody's freedom
today Medicare is a very popular program
Medicaid is a popular program yeah so
it's going to take an effort but I think
two points John on this issue number one
we as Americans have got to ask
ourselves how come every other major
country guarantees health care to all
people at far lower costs per capita
than we do that's number one number two
fundamental question is health care a
human right or is it not if you have the
money your kid is sick you can get great
health
you don't have the money your kid is
sick you're in trouble or you may go
bankrupt after you come out of an
expensive hospital procedure we can do
better as a nation quick question about
the politics of this the Democratic
Party just benefit from a revolutionary
response at the ballot box in winning 40
seats in a house in the Senate Democrats
didn't do as well because of the
structure of the way it works we had a
lot of seats you know that we have to
defend of course but that's part of the
structure of the way politics works my
question to you is you talk about a
revolution
you just had a revolution in 2018
essentially and it was unable to get
past the structural system in the Senate
on revolutions do not happen overnight
now one of the revolutions that I am
very proud of it's not just that many of
the ideas that we brought forth in 2016
are now supported by a strong majority
of the American people it's that we are
getting more people ordinary people
young people participating in the
political process and I think the future
of the Democratic Party frankly is
bringing young people black and white
and Latino and Native American and
asian-american into the political
process and I'm very proud and we're
gonna build on this that in the last
campaign you know we lost got 46 percent
of the pledged delegates but we won more
votes from young people then Clinton and
Trump did combined does your success
hurt in the marketplace of ideas which
is to say Alexandria Ocasio Cortez can
talk about a green new deal and is
getting a lot of coverage for that but
that shrinks the amount of time that
people are maybe paying attention to
Bernie Sanders or some other idea does
it change the marketplace of ideas quite
the country the fact that we have more
voices out there talking in this case
about the existential threat to our
country in the world which is what
climate change is and the absolute need
to transform our energy system away from
fossil fuel to energy efficiency and
sustainable energy and by the way when
we do that we create millions of
good-paying jobs and we are going to pay
attention to our brothers and sisters in
the fossil fuel industry
who will be hurt by this transition
we're not going to lead them on the side
of the road you were supportive of the
fact that an Amazon pulled out of New
York City that it that that deal did not
go through I once and but I was also
supportive and maybe at the lead of
telling Amazon owned by the wealthiest
person in the world that they cannot
continue to pay their employees nine or
ten or eleven dollars an hour they had
to raise the minimum wage their minimum
wage to eleven bucks now which is you
recall or happened we did that with
Disney as well what you have and with a
company like Amazon is a very profitable
company owned by the wealthiest guy in
the world
who among other things we recently
learned paid zero federal taxes so
you're a worker out there making forty
or fifty thousand bucks yeah you pay
more in taxes than Amazon did that made
billions of dollars in profit and what I
did not like about what they did to New
York that's New York's decision not mine
but I don't like a powerful company kind
of playing off one state or one city
against another all right you're wrong
Los Angeles what are you gonna give me
you're in New York City what are you
gonna give me how much corporate welfare
are you gonna give me because I have
some jobs I don't think that's a good
way to do business in America corporate
tax rates gonna go up under Bernice
absolutely how am i well I can't give
you yeah that's something we're gonna
think about but let's deal with this I
will tell you this very frankly John I
worry very much that in our country and
you could hear anyone else tell you this
yucky heard on CBS too much so on is
that this country is moving toward an
oligarchic form of society and that
means that we have a small number of
billionaires Jeff Bezos being one who
have enormous economic and political
power and that's why I've introduced a
very progressive estate tax to deal with
that issue but at a time when we have so
many social needs when we have children
in this country who were going hungry
when we have veterans who were sleeping
down on the street when we have to
combat climate change you know what yeah
we all get I ask the billionaires and
the wealthiest people to stop paying
their fair share of taxes no apologies
on my part what's your opinion of cap
ilysm these days what cat what's your
opinion of capitalism look I think what
we see in this country around the world
is a lot of great entrepreneurs who come
up with some great ideas and some great
products but I think what is happening
is some of these folks we are have a
system which allows these people to
accumulate huge amounts of income and
wealth so when I talk about democratic
socialism you know talking about the
government running the local grocery
store or anything else like that what we
are saying is that in America and by the
way Franklin Delano Roosevelt talked
about this way back in the 1940s that
people are entitled not only to certain
constitutional political rights they are
entitled to economic rights so somebody
wants to call me a rat achill ok here it
is I believe that people are inherently
entitled to health care I believe people
are entitled to get the best education
they can I believe that people are
entitled to live in a clean environment
people are entitled to have decent
paying jobs that's what I believe the
president mentioned socialism in his
State of the Union what's he going after
there he's gonna appeal he's gonna lie
he's gonna say Bernie Sanders wants the
United States to become Venezuela Bernie
Sanders does not want to have the United
States become the horrific economic
situation that unfortunately exists in
Venezuelan right now what Bernie Sanders
wants is to learn from countries around
the world Bernie Sanders wants to learn
from Finland in terms of why they have
the highest quality public educational
system in the world learn from Sweden
and Denmark why they have virtually free
childcare and quite quality free health
care for their people why other
countries doing a better job in dealing
with income and wealth inequality than
we are so you got a president who is a
demagogue a president who is leading us
in an authoritarian direction I would
hope that the American people don't
believe too much of what he says
Kratts you know this well come to you
and say you're not a Democrat why are
you running in the Democratic primary
well first of all I am a member of the
Democratic leadership I've been in the
Democratic caucus I'm part of the
leadership in the Senate I have been
part of the Democratic caucus in the
house the sixteen years and I will say
this in terms of that so and I have
knocked my brains out running around the
country to help Democrats win the house
the help governor's when Democratic
governors win their seats
but this is what I will also say if you
look at polling in this country what you
find is that a whole lot of people are
dissatisfied with both the Democratic
and Republican parties usually the
Republicans come out lowest Democrats
and more and more people are seeing
themselves as independents so if I if
the Democratic Party is going to do well
in the future I think they have to reach
out to those independence including by
the way a lot of young people a lot of
people of color and bring them into the
Democratic Party and I think I'm in a
good position to do the revolution
you're talking about does it require
making a moral case about wealth in
America in other words not just that it
shouldn't be concentrated but that the
people who are concentrated with that
wealth are bad people that's part of
what fueled the uprising in the Gilded
Age against look I I wouldn't use it
that way I mean there are some bad
people who are poor there are bad people
who are rich there are bad people who
are middle-class there are bad people of
black did white and everything else I
don't I don't look at it that way what I
look at it is is we have created a
system which is basically out of control
and that system is that you have
billionaire corporations billion
corporations like Amazon that make
billions of profit don't pay a nickel in
taxes you have three people who own more
wealth than the bottom half of American
society that is the sure it's not those
three people it is that we have allowed
that to take place so I got we got
veterans sleeping out on the street we
have kids who can't afford to go to
college you got 30 million people have
no health care and then you've got three
people on more wealth than the bottom
half of America that is wrong that's
morally wrong in my view that
is bad economics the system in
Washington that you're familiar with
even though you're trying to run a
revolution from the outside is it
possible to have bipartisan let's reason
together in Washington or do you need to
do things like get rid of the filibuster
to break through some of the systemic
things that block both Republicans and
Democrats though but I think the problem
is people often talk about the lack of
comedy and anger the real issue is that
you have in Washington a system which is
dominated by wealthy campaign
contributors who in their right mind so
you go out do a poll all right here's a
suggestion CBS do a poll do you think it
is a good idea to give a trillion
dollars in tax breaks that the top 1%
and private corporations and then cut
Social Security Medicare and Medicaid
that's the Republican agenda what
percentage of the American people
support that 5% 10% nobody and yet
that's what happens why because
billionaires and wealthy campaign
contributors significantly control what
goes on in Washington and that is why
among many other things we have to
overturn citizens united we have to do
away with this horrible voter
suppression every American regardless of
your political view should be outraged
that you have governors and attorney
generals in this country trying to keep
people from voting because of their
color or because of their economic
status outrageous let me ask you about a
theory that Howard Schultz Howard
Schultz has now said he would not run as
an independent if the Democrats moderate
but you raise a good thing why is Howard
Schultz on every television station in
this country why are you quoting Howard
Schultz because he's a billionaire all
right there are a lot of people I know
personally who work hard for a living to
make 40 $50,000 eeeh who know a lot more
about politics than all due respect as
mr. Schultz but because we have a
corrupt political system anybody who is
a billionaire who can throw a lot of TV
ads on television
suddenly becomes very very credible so
what mr. Schulz
what is he blackmailing the Democratic
Party if you don't nominate Bernie
Sanders he's not gonna run well I don't
think we should succumb to that kind of
blackmail the other reason is that he
represents an argument that some people
make which is if you're worried about
Donald Trump the Democratic Party to win
voters in various parts of the country
needs to pick somebody who is not so
radical that's also what his theory well
I think his deeper theory is hey I'm a
billionaire leave me alone and let me
make as much money as I can without
paying my fair share of taxes and let me
continue and have undue political fluids
which you are quoting me all right here
is a billionaire no one's ever heard of
this guy well not many people have he's
a billionaire it's thinking of running
for president something is a very famous
guy that's that is a problem
with our political system you'll be 79
when you're inaugurated yes
that's all by the standards such
presidents yes what should people be
concerned about that I think you know
when we look at people whether they're
older they're young you got to look at
the totality of of the person I'm sure
you have bumped into people 190 who do
great work you have bumped into people
who are 45 or 50 you got to wake up cuz
they're falling asleep all of the time I
have been blessed thank God I'm gonna
knock this is what I'm gonna knock on it
with with good health and with good
energy so cross-country runner a
long-distance runner when I was a kid
and I've been running hard in a sense
since then so you know I think as a
nation is we try to stand up and oppose
all forms of discrimination whether it
is racism with sexism or homophobia or
Islamophobia whatever it may be I think
we gotta take a hard look at ageism as
well as well judge a person on you know
whether you like them with their ideas
that make sense what do you think they
could do the job I think that's how we
should look if people are running for
office and not just on one criteria by
age we're out of time but I get a couple
more questions for you there has been
talk Andrew McKay was the deputy
director of the FBI as the book out he
talked about the
Fifth Amendment with respect to this
president you're thinking of being
president is it wise for the institution
of the presidency to have a have kind of
informal talk about the 25th amendment a
lot of progressives like the idea is
that good and healthy promises you know
look all that I will I will answer that
question by saying this they are right
now a number of investigations most
significantly the Muller investigation
looking in this case whether there was
collusion between the Trump campaign and
Russia yeah I think it's a little bit
preliminary to be giving you answers
before we see the results of those
investigations it should be people be
talking about the 25th amendment okay uh
I don't talk about it foreign policy you
wanted America out of a lot of the wars
that it was engaged in Donald Trump
wants that too you said about North
Korea that it was a that it was a good
first step to D ask a positive step to
deescalate tensions it would seem like
Donald Trump's foreign policy is in sync
with no it's not in in the sense a Trump
has gone it appears has gone out of his
way to antagonize a long term allies I
mean to insult our Canadian neighbors to
insult Germany or the United Kingdom
France is you know almost
incomprehensible on the other hand I
have called for you absolutely right I
think the idea that we are going to
withdraw troops from Syria or from
Afghanistan is is the right thing but it
has to be done not through a tweet and
this is not easy stuff you can't turn
your backs on your allies you can't
leave people in danger so the idea of
getting out of was that we have been in
for a very long time is good but it has
got to be done in the right way it has
to be done with our allies not through
tweets last question there were charges
in your last campaign that women felt
there was discrimination against them
that there were sexism you met with some
of those former staffers what did you
learn I learned that that was true and
it breaks my heart and you know our
campaign kind of exploded went from a
few people to a lot of people and I will
be very honest in telling you that in
retrospect some of the people that were
hired should not have been hired and
some women went through experiences that
they should not have but let me also say
this in my 2018 campaign for re-election
to the United States Senator from
Vermont and in this campaign for
president we are going to have the
strongest protocols to protect women or
anybody else against any form of
harassment we are going to be training
every employee who works for us and
we're gonna give people who feel that
they've been harassed the opportunity to
talk to people outside of the campaign
so this has been an issue that has upset
me and we're gonna rectify it in this
campaign senator Sanders thank you thank
you very much